[Music]
well Meg super excited that you're able
to join on the this is gonna be the
first episode exit strategy podcast I'm
super excited that you're here just a
little bit of background about Nick Nick
is the co-founder and CEO of thrive
market thrive market is like a Costco
meets Whole Foods online business he was
also an investor in the business that
I'd started native I think you know you
were one of the bedrocks of native in
terms of our investor base I'd give you
a call and tell you about all the
problems I had all the time and you were
really calm about that I mean you didn't
have that many investors so I didn't
have that many investors but there were
even fewer that I felt like I could
trust and give a call to and you were
certainly one of them so I always
appreciated that can you start out and
tell everyone a little bit about thrive
market in the off chance that they don't
know about it already
yeah so first just honored to be here
super upsetting to get to do something
like this I mean my work from home
office right now so it's it's a
convenient time as well yeah to be here
and excited to be to be jamming with you
and it's setting where we're not solving
business problems we were just getting
to play yeah okay that's right
so thrive market is you mean you
described it well I think the easiest
way for people that don't know about the
business to get it is to think you know
Costco membership club needs Whole Foods
catalog all delivered online with
increasingly I'd say a bit Trader Joe's
blended in so when we launched we were
carrying basically the top 78,000
natural organic products that you find
in a health food store and then through
the membership making them available at
twenty five to fifty percent off so
mission is make healthy living
affordable and accessible to anybody
ship anywhere in the country fast and
free now we actually have not only all
those products but also a lot of our own
products so you know fully 1/3 of our
sales are on the thrive market brand so
you know we started out very much a
retailer online I'd say now we're this
strange hybrid beast between a retailer
a brand and really a community platform
online where our members are going to us
not just to buy products but to learn
how to use them and to participate in
campaigns and initiatives that align
around their
their values and their impact on issues
like sustainability and can you talk a
little bit about the history of the
brand like when did you guys start that
when did you guys start you know what
what size are you at today what's the
growth look like how big is the team
yeah so we I mean I could spend hours
just answering that question we we
started back in 2014
unlike native we didn't have a lien we
don't didn't have the capital
requirements so you know we spent the
better part of the first year
self-funded the business and kind of
getting up the starting line
we tried to raise more capital and we
got rejected by 150 plus species so you
know first of many existential crises in
the business and launched I guess
October of 2014 and we finally got live
and the the really fortunate thing that
happened to us actually ended up being
that we were rejected by so many pcs
that we raised all of our initial money
from health and wellness influencers who
turned out to be the best promoters of
the business as well so we had this you
know probably 100 plus kind of Coalition
of the Willing that was on our cap table
and then also promoting the business and
grew very very fast pretty much from day
one you know we have over 700,000
members today we're doing hundreds and
millions of dollars in sales you know
five years in and still growing big
double digits per year and so can you
talk about that first year you said that
you know you got rejected by dozens of
VCS it was you and three other
co-founders and you were sort of
bootstrapping the business early on what
was the cost of that and was that model
is sort of the same model that thrive
market ultimately became or did you were
you guys bootstrapping something
slightly different
I mean look like like so many businesses
we were iterating in real time all the
time for the first really for the first
several years and in that first year
before we got live it was you know
almost like the business model morphed
every day yeah the very very initial
model was going to be a basically
Groupon for healthy food so when ganar
pitched me back at the very very
beginning you know I was a I'd sold my
last company was an entrepreneur
residence at a startup accelerator
probably saw
fifteen pitches a day had seen hundreds
over the prior few months and you know
ganar came in and pitched me on the idea
he was calling shop tribe and the idea
was to literally build this was like
back in 2013 to build Groupon for
healthy food so Groupon was like the big
thing buying it yes we're gonna change
the world I was the way that everyone
was gonna buy everything why not do it
we were Suri's but what captivated me
was the the mission was exactly what it
is today which is let's make healthy
living accessible to anybody and the
initial idea was let's pool people's
people's funds by with a wholesale
account from these brands directly and
cut out all the middlemen and cut the
prices by 25 to 50% off so that organic
and natural products right below the
conventional equivalent so this is a
crazy sorry sorry interrupt isn't it
crazy how like e-commerce Ehrlich
startups are fashionable you know in
like twelve and twenty thirteen Groupon
for X was fashionable like a few goes
goes like uber for X is fashionable yeah
you know we we iterated we iterated
through every fashionable business model
no like we like we were briefly gonna be
a subscription box right for poor
healthy food so you know the challenge
that we are trying to solve or the
problem we were trying to solve was how
do you make these natural organic
products which at retail tend to be 25
to 50 percent more expensive than
conventional accessible to anybody and
that first barrier was price so Groupon
was one way to solve that but it
involved getting your groceries on a you
know 10 to 15 day delay or more as we
tried to buy direct and it involved you
know getting your your coconut oil one
day and getting your chips the next day
out getting your toilet paper the next
day just didn't really didn't really
work so where we ultimately land it was
an evergreen catalog and then this the
membership model so really started
studying Costco closely and realized
that allows you to basically run your
product business at zero margin because
all the margin comes off with the
membership and then for us there's
especially positive powerful because we
use every paid membership to actually
sponsor a free membership for a
low-income family so it sort of
turbocharged the mission at the same
time where it doesn't actually cost us
anything to let those low income
families and they actually in fact will
drive product sales which gives us poor
volume
but it baked in that ability to truly
you know get get margin from people that
people that can pay but be accessible to
anybody else yeah
Costco is business model is crazy when
you look at the 10k their net profit is
basically the equivalent of the
membership feed revenue that they
generate and they also limit the margin
that they take on any given product and
I think for luck you know Kirkland
products it's like 13% for other types
of products it's something like 11%
those numbers might be off by a little
bit and I remember I read this one story
where the Kirkland C ants are the
Cossacks itting on the board of
directors of start at Starbucks and
Howard Schultz was like guys great news
coffee prices are going down we're not
reducing prices so our margins are going
up and so he goes to Howard Schultz
after the meeting and he's like when are
you gonna give us a break on coffee
prices and Howard Schultz is like we're
not intending to pass along any savings
discounts to retailers like Costco and
he's like great we're gonna eliminate
Starbucks coffee from all cost cos
pretty soon because you're not passing
this along and Howard Schultz is like
okay we'll give you a price discount on
cents which speaks to cost goes you know
scale and position with their with their
vendors but also I think your bigger
your bigger point is obviously if they
pass everything along and their value to
the members is the savings on the
membership right and that was very much
where we started you know the
interesting thing is today the value is
actually much more right it's the
ability to vote you know vote with your
dollars for brands whose values you
align to it's the ability to get you
know all the highest quality products
curated in one place it's the ability to
shop buy buy your dietary needs and
things like that
so it's interesting some of the ways the
businesses to verge from from Costco
sure but fundamentally that first thing
we had to solve was how do we make it
affordable that only happens if we can
go without margin that only happens if
we have another source of margin and
that was membership and so it's 2014 all
these VCS have said no to you how much
of your own capital how much of you how
much do you put down in order to like
start the business in order to pivot
from shop drive to ultimately what
becomes the right market so slow low six
figures you know is that not listen or
is that altogether
each no ganar me each individually so I
mean I could go into the whole kind of
like saga we
you know we spent $100,000 alone on an
agency to build the website which we
found out two weeks before we were
thinking we are going to launch it
basically wasn't even started I was like
like our ship shows our level of
sophistication we brought in Sasha our
third co-founder at that moment of
crisis and I remember going to to Sam
teller who is a good friend of mine and
was running this struck me as a actually
venture investor now but at the time was
running the startup accelerator
Launchpad LA and I'm like who in LA is
the best C CTO for startups like
wherever they are whatever they're doing
we need to hire them we'll give will
give them whatever percentage of the
company they do now like we're in it
word our you know we're the Nexus
tential crisis and he's like Sasha
artha and fortunately he just rolled off
his last business and bridged with
another one unfortunately he's talking
to like 40 other companies right now ya
know we like you know we more or less
locked him in a room and didn't let him
leave till he's totally til I came on as
our as our fourth co-founder and you
know had we not done that we literally
went have gotten to launch so you know
we spend $100,000 there we spent a bunch
of money just on payroll ramping up
thinking we were gonna launch before we
before we did we spent you know it was
it was like every mistake you can think
of making we probably made and we had no
excuse to be doing it either because
both ganar and I were serial
entrepreneurs we both started and sold
businesses before but it was this very
humbling reminder that like starting
something is hard
sure learning takes time and taken the
same lesson at least twice before you
really learn it and and like I said it
in the end a lot of those things ended
up being the best things that ever
happened to us right we failed to raise
money we ended up getting connecting
with all the influencers we failed a bit
at build a site we brought on the right
co-founder who to this day is our CTO
you know header product and drives huge
amounts of values value in the business
so you know it was it was it was
challenging but yet like we wouldn't be
here where we are had we not stumbled so
much early on and were you worried early
on when you sort of spent six figures
you're like well you poss are we doing
here yes yes thousand times yes how old
you're being calm
Rises you been calling me like yeah we
spent six figures and things weren't
working if I if it happened to be a
doing even today I'd be like I cannot
believe this happened
no I we weren't calm at all we were you
know here's like moments of real despair
you know sleepless night it's like all
the all the cliched things you would do
if you're like pouring honey into a
black hole and not seeing anything come
out we were feeling so no and it wasn't
you know you can look back on it now and
it seems like the whole trajectory seems
inevitable and this led to this and that
led to that but the only thing clearly
was leading to at the time was more
failure so it was they were some of the
darkest darkest times of my
entrepreneurial life for sure probably
in my life in general
I mean you question everything right in
the business model you questioned your
selection of partner instruction you
question yourself of course right like
like was I did I just get lucky the
first time like am i regressing to the
mean here yeah absolutely yeah and so so
you launch the site it's on Magento
which I think that like people don't
talk about enough is there tech stack
like I remember talking to Christopher
Gavin once from honest and he's like
we're reap lat forming for the third
time you know in our life at honest and
I was like that seems like a lot of work
you guys have been on Magento you're
doing hundreds of millions of dollars a
year is Magento amazing is Magento
better than Shopify like why Magento I
guess so I mean that's a technical
question you should spend some time with
Sasha on yeah he would laugh if he
urghhh you've been asking me that
question but it is you know there's
there's pros and cons right every
platform has its pros and cons but Gento
is very scalable it's also got a really
like like robust set of kind of
off-the-shelf applications that you can
sure that you can use Shopify does too
and there's a there's a large developer
community so the ability to scale up
engineering resources to get going
quickly was really imperative at the
time we've obviously felt a lot of
pressure to launch being six months out
individually intended to yeah and so you
know that was a that was the call that
Sasha
I think there's definitely been some
challenges with Magento - not to say
that it wouldn't have been other
challenges with any platform we selected
so we've we've actually some of the core
e-commerce infrastructure is still on
Magento but a lot of the front facing
aspects the features of the site and
applications we've actually pulled off
and put in to react and and other other
platforms okay so you're it's 2014
you've spent six figures you've pivoted
from shop tribe and a bunch of different
models to what ultimately becomes thrive
yeah we're still shop drive until two
weeks before we launch by the way Wow
let's create and I could show you yeah I
can show you our our color was magenta
was screwed up - sounds like Magento but
it was magenta as in like a cross
between purple and pink that was all
that was the color of the site like the
whole branding was that you know our our
logo is essentially a gemstone and the
company was called shop tribe you know
it was not it was not positioned the way
it needed to and that actually is a
story behind our 4th co-founder Kate
Mullen who is a brilliant writer and
content content curator editor and brand
brand mind and she came in and basically
was like guys this wasn't gonna work you
know this this and this and I took her
two months to convince us to move off of
shop tribe so I mean weeks before we
were launching I was spending time on
the phone with some you know website
squatter in Florida trying to buy tribe
market calm unless we be forced to
launch it Wow okay what did you pay for
it ah low it was five like between ten
twenty thousand dollars gotcha
you know I'm not sure I told you this
but when native was trying to sell when
we were trying to sell our business we
had all like we hadn't we didn't own our
trademark and I I think I might have
mentioned that if she mentioned this to
you while you were investing and I was
like I probably didn't wanna I probably
don't want to hear this you were
actually you were like you need to go
solve your trademark issues because
we've had a lot of trademark issues
and so you know I was like you know sort
of it was sort of on the back burner
where I was like okay I need to solve
these trademark issues M&A is coming up
like down the road and I'm like okay
these trademark issues are becoming more
important and you know at one point we
had signed like you know we'd signed not
a term sheet but like a letter of intent
or something to that effect with with
P&G and PN G's like you need to go buy
your trade like the only thing holding
up the transaction was our trademark and
so we purchased the trademark from two
people living in the middle of like
North Dakota on a Friday and then I'm
like the next week on Wednesday we sold
the business five days later but it was
literally the only thing holding us up
from our I'm guessing you paid more than
$20,000 or your money no no substantial
like more than 10x I felt like we had to
do it we're like we never bought Native
calm but we had to do is either that or
we had to retain like change our name
and sort of restart the business and
prove that we could do it under a
different name and yeah I mean look
we've had we've had different challenges
with dry market - and probably some some
similar to native right you've got a
term that is already out of the
zeitgeist and there's a lot of common
use already of them or some of the marks
so it was one of the trade-offs right
with with R I love like do we go with
something that really evokes something
powerful but it's gonna be less ownable
from a trademark standpoint where do we
try to create you know Nike which is
that a totally new word and very own
Abul but you know building brand equity
around that's gonna take a lot of time
so trademark is under underappreciated
it's one of those things that you don't
think about until until you know there
was always pretty been a lot of value
built in the business in most cases but
if you can solve it early it saves a lot
of headache down the road yeah and if
someone else on through trademark they
have monopsony power right like you they
have the only out set that you need and
you cannot go anywhere else for it and
it's a lot of trouble okay so it's 2014
you've launched the site you've
rebranded to thrive market because you
realized shop tribe is a big mistake the
gemstones out the magenta color is out
how do you get your first like you know
hundred thousand dollars and cents I
mean it was just influencers so this was
another social aggregate you had
influencers it was 100 percent right so
we raised we ended up because we
couldn't raise money from any one
institutional because no investors were
put in it we went to basically health
and wellness influencers and asked them
to invest in the company in addition to
being affiliate partners and what we
found out is it not only brought in
capital very slowly like we was like ten
to twenty five thousand dollar
investments but we brought in whatever
it was 50 to 100 these folks they were
totally aligned with the mission they
got what we were trying to do they cared
about it themselves they many of them
became and have become good friends of
ours right who are not just you know
financial partners the business but true
supporters of our cause and all of those
the dynamics cause them to also want to
promote in a very different way than
they would have if it was just a
transactional relationship so they were
they were stakeholders they were aligned
with vision they got something less as
people they understood what we were
trying to do with the business and when
they started talking to their audiences
about it they saw you know mom just
monster reactions and so it was it was
actually too much too soon I can
remember our original warehouse was in
the center of our office or offices call
it 6000 square feet and to give you a
sense of like we have 800 thousand
square feet of fulfillment center space
today so the entire warehouse fit along
with all of us into an office that was
6,000 square feet you know we ended up
having within two or three weeks we had
storage containers in our driveway that
we had racked and been that we were like
fulfilling that of you know we like in
her entire driveway it was filled with
just boxes like stacked so high you
couldn't see the sky thing so it was it
was crazy but there was no once we
actually got live and with these really
value elide authentic and supportive
influencers talking about us who was
like there was no turning back
so we believe through that defense yeah
and and so they agreed to invest prior
to you having $1 in sales
virtually call it 80% of the influencers
that ultimately like were it like and
many of whom still continue to be
amazing partners came in before we had a
dollar sales which is you know it's very
it's a really interesting kind of window
into the way BC is think versus the way
you know kind of a value or values
driven mission oriented investor things
every VC said no right none of them
could see it yeah and our success rate
with the influencers was probably
seventy to eighty percent close right
you know like three out of four then
were coming in and there was two things
that they contributed to that one was
they just got the they got the value
proposition they entered sure that
healthy have a healthy living maybe is
he healthy living at affordable matters
and it matters to millions of people
because those millions of people were
also the people that were their
audiences and then the second side of it
was and this goes back to like when I
was you know kind of the ways that we
got help early on from specific
individuals but we had one of my buddies
from college john durant who's basically
a meta influencer you know to influence
her to the influencers if you will and
you know coming in through a trusted
trusted person that that they really
looked to and followed made a massive
massive difference so he opened up the
doors and then as the dominoes started
to fall every influencer knew more
influencers are sure to just spiral
beginners so we have four hundred people
on a cap table today so was was john to
rent the first influencer so that signed
up who was the first influencer john
durant predated all the influencers yeah
the first free did the first influencer
they came on board was mark Sisson of
primal nation at the time this is pre
primal kitchen behind you right so he
was just mark Sisson of marks daily
apple yeah yeah but a mega influencer in
paleo and back in 2013 2014 paleo was
was much bigger like keto wasn't even on
the scene so paleo was the biggest the
biggest sort of lifestyle
tribe that we were going after and John
introduced us to to mark then he
introduced us to wellness mama which is
but who's been our biggest influencer of
all total and then it was just one after
the other after that so you know we got
very very lucky with from a people side
right just getting the right people come
the business at the right time and then
we got very very fortunate to find
people that actually like I said cared
about the mission like that was the
thing that if we hadn't if we didn't
really we were doing it for the right
reasons does influence respond to come
on board it's also spectacular to get
people who are basically going to be
your customers to become your advocates
as well like nothing more authentic than
that so till one I think I've heard you
say in the past that you didn't spend a
dollar in paid media in the first year
and how much look at what our sales look
like the first year and what is you what
is the first like you know you've raised
from I don't know four hundred
influencers or something to that effect
you know within a year one of them
cutting you checks because I imagine it
wasn't like one round I'm actually sort
of it was investing a check at a time
yeah it's rolling how much have they
investor so we raised eight and a half
million dollars before before doing a
series a we did the series a nine months
after we launched and we were probably
at a forty million dollar run rate at
that point you know we did over thirty
million dollars in the first year so it
was it was crazy so we stood up a 40,000
square foot fulfillment center you know
over the course of like six days I
remember at one point five for five
months in now it was just like doing
whatever we could to meet the volume and
also in many cases asking influencers
not to talk about us right it was like
this like crazy backwards situation
where it was there was so much demand we
could we didn't know what to do with
this so to be honest we probably could
have done more in sales in the first
year than we did and it was very
vindicating or very validating of the
core thesis of the model right because
what the what the feces were always
skeptical of is that you know normal
middle class middle American people want
to get healthy it was like no no they're
they're out there like this is my
background I grew up in in Minnesota so
I know that people in Midwest and the
southeast many of whom don't live near a
Whole Foods want this but you know VC
who lives in San Francisco and doesn't
do his own grocery shopping you know
yeah sure not in touch with it so it was
it was incredible to see that come in
where it was like more demand we knew it
with and and coming from people that
were you know everyday middle post
middle Americans is there anyone who you
know initially told you no we're not
going to fund you that came back and
ultimately invested or tried to invest
in the series in a lot of a lot of them
and some of them it was like oh come on
right like when they when you yeah cool
it would tell they would tell you that
you're gonna fail right or yet the
people that like listen and like you
know nodded and stuff and I just didn't
respond to your emails so you know those
are not the people you're gonna let it
dance but we also had a lot of people
that gave really well reasoned
explanations for why they weren't
investing and the truth is like we were
it's a high-risk bet right it's an
operational intensive business now
they're ganaron or I had e-commerce
experience we're going up against Amazon
Whole Foods at the time we're not the
same business right of course yeah and
and so we had some some some folks that
were really really thoughtful one of
them was was Dana settle like gray Croft
who said no but said hey I also love
what you're doing I love the mission I
aligned a lifestyle myself as a mom I
see the value proposition and I believed
in what you're doing it's too early and
the risk profile is not right for us
right now but let's talk talking in a
few months and she continued to follow
up and like that's who we went with yeah
in this year and you didn't do any of
those like Silicon Valley I'm gonna take
the meeting and just [__] on you for
being [__] to me type of like
arounds when you do your Series A or
Series B I did those no and I did those
all in my head I like fantasy moments
but no never ever actually picked up the
phone and made that call
gotcha so this guy Erlich Bachman goes
into VC meetings and like he's like you
know what I'm sensing that you guys
aren't the right fit in like the VC
meetings and he'll be like you know
these pastries are [__] and one time he
takes his balls out and he actually puts
them on the conference room table to be
like [__] you and you know there were a
bunch of me and on my style yeah no yeah
yeah of course you think about that
though not that specifically but like a
wizard thing
about you know like those rejections
were so painful right like if you're
someone who's competitive if you're
someone who succeeded things that
they've done in the past to be you know
to be told no it's hard to be ignored is
even harder right like honestly that was
the worst was like the people who don't
even give you the time of day sure so it
was it was super hard but again it was
super formative and like at the end of
the day I have to be grateful to those
people because we wind up gone to the
influencers had those guys said yes and
I don't think sure would have build the
kind of company that we have uh and so
you launch how big is your catalog in
year one year two we probably launched
with 4,500 SKUs and scale it up to 65
minute equip
so it's been more or less stable I mean
we I alluded to this earlier but that
first barrier we wanted to break down
was affordability but the there's all
sorts of other barriers to getting
healthy one of them is actually just the
intimidation factor of like where the
hell do I start right and if you if you
walk into a Whole Foods they haven't
been in a bowl foods before choosing
between 50 almond butters it's like
totally overwhelming right if you search
for almond butter on Amazon you're gonna
see 40,000 results so we actually part
of our value is to be hyper curated to
be that place that is your trusted
resource where you don't have to think
about whether this is the right quality
everything reaches our high quality bar
and we're gonna recommend the best
products in each category for you and
that stayed the same so we're still
we're you know our prod our catalog has
probably grown less than 500 SKUs in the
last two to three years Wow and so
they're like is there a lot of recycling
among the SKUs like are you pushing yeah
okay got your net okay so we're yeah I
mean the trends are always changing as
you can imagine and we're you know we
mix shift we're always always always
looking to go deeper with the brands
that really align with our values with
the brands that really are authentic
that have amazing stories that are doing
real innovation and we don't want on as
the brand that's like become
commoditized become lazy you know just
sort of turning the turning the crank
and if that's the case we'll go into
private label and we'll do it ourselves
and we'll do it better and so that's
that's been actually one of the most
exciting things is to see like we can
reward these amazing innovative
we will invest in deep with them and
then in the areas the catalog where
there's not as much happening its
innovative on the third-party side we
can go to the innovation ourselves right
so we work with 40 co-packers now on our
own brand we're sourcing from supply
chains literally all over the world so
our product innovators you know
notwithstanding our current period but
normally they're traveling all over the
world all the time sure
and we're now getting to a scale where
we can actually like build supply chains
ourselves so like we you know we're
working with the farmers collective in
Patagonia that didn't exist before
thrive market you know we're standing up
this collective that is helping to
convert farmers down there to
traditional grass-fed beef practices
that's you know cool stuff like that
that's been just amazing and so when you
have a catalog of 4,500 products or 6500
products later on how do you like or you
know Facebook has this of had this
amazing realization early on that if you
were able to get seven friends in 10
days you'd get addicted to Facebook
slack says that once a team has sent out
two thousand messages internally in
slacks or has you know has had two
thousand slacks people are addicted to
slack and will not churn
is there some sort of North Star that
you were looking for there would you
like if we can get you to make five
purchases in the first month or if we
can get you to purchase kettle and fire
bone broth in the first year you know
you're gonna get hooked to our brand
yeah there's a there's a bunch of those
there's a there's a big question in my
mind always of how much of those like
how much of that is correlation versus
causation right and as soon as you start
to do things to drive the behavior the
correlation and the causation can start
to break down yeah but I mean the the
most obvious thing is if people order
they will stay period like the most
important proxy for value and it's not
even really a proxy it is the source of
value is people getting products that
they love and coming back to buy those
products again so you know we will like
the first order is sacrosanct for us we
want to drive as many people the moment
that they join the membership to be
placing a first order within 30 days and
that's you know days zero we look at day
zero day seven day thirty day
day 30 order rates we also have a
concept we call core members so those
are members that have placed form or
lifetime orders and what's interesting
is we got regardless of the rate that
takes you to the rate that those orders
are placed in or how long it takes you
to get there once you have placed four
orders there's a really significant
inflection and in stick right and we're
you know we're pretty lucky and that the
upfront membership fee also act as as a
filter to get people who truly aren't
invest in a life cycle I think one of
the biggest mistakes we made early on
the marketing side was trying to convert
people right that's not our that's not
actually what we can do today as we get
bigger scale and go more mainstream
maybe that'll be something for the
future but today what we want to do is
capture the people that already want
this lifestyle that are working really
hard to achieve it but don't have the
best option and as soon as we start we
call that the wellness champion and you
know if we can go after those people
bring them in and get them the first
order that is you know those people are
gonna get a renu-it a very high rate and
today our renewal rate annually are over
70 percent so it's it's not as high as
Costco but I think if you looked at part
of the reason Costco's are over 90 as
they've titrated the membership base
over so many years if you look at you
know apples and apples our first two
your second year 30 or renewal rates I
bet were on par would be my would be my
hypothesis and they don't they don't
obviously don't publish their cohort
data sure sure yeah and so what does
that mean in terms of people so people
who buy memberships what percentage are
buying an actual product in the first 30
days so it depends on the source of the
traffic but half of people will order in
the first or purchase your first 30 days
yeah almost almost a third of them will
place in order of the first day and you
know we used to actually have used to be
a hundred percent because literally the
way you would start your trial
membership was by placing the first
order that's something we actually
decoupled those two steps I call it it's
really two problems in one there's a I
call the basket building problem and
then the the membership problem and
neither one is really a problem but it's
like it's it's it's a it's a task that
we have to do so we have
convince someone that it's worth
spending $60 a year on a membership and
then we have to get them to place an
order which is not trivial for us
because the average unit value is only
six dollars the average order size was
over 70 so we're getting them to put 10
to 15 or even 20 items into a card
that's a 40 to 50 minute exercise for
most people on their first order
so our CPAs are where I'm sure are I'm
sure higher than the native CPAs okay
but but the value of that customer if
you can get them to place that order is
white I absolutely would you know a
native our average order value is about
20 to 21 dollars and we also saw the
same inflection point which is if you
purchase native four times you are never
going to use another TIA we have you and
we were really excited about that so you
know we were talking about like how
categories change and I went from like
the world has gone from paleo taquito
you know for native like deodorant also
went from deodorant charcoal deodorant
became a much bigger thing and never
existed a few years ago what are some of
the categories that you've seen sort of
grow at thrive and what are the
categories that are like the largest if
you could talk about that today yeah I
mean we can spend a while talking just
about charcoal if you want that's that's
been one of the most bizarre trends and
it's sort of across all categories you
have charcoal in your beverage charcoal
and your deodorant it's important it's
like faded a bit right and like all
these all of these all of these trends
right the the faster they rise that the
faster they fall typically you know 2019
was all about CBD you know the CBD hemp
extract and you know we were seeing I
mean of like growth rates that we had
never seen in any category period to the
point that CBD was becoming one of our
top five subcategories on the entire
site and it's still doing really well
but it's stabilized and then it's and
then dropped off I think for some of the
more commoditized commoditized skews
quito continues to be huge and it has
been for now a year and a half to two
years you know looked at some of the
Google search trends and it's definitely
had a little bit but that hasn't gotten
a case for us we're still seeing that as
at a diet
dwarf all of their dietary search terms
combined so it's that big and you know
plant-based is as you'd imagine is also
really really significant I think one of
the most heartening trends that we've
seen on-site in general has been more
interest in environmental responsibility
and sustainability so you know just an
anecdote there where carbon neutral or
shipping we actually buy offsets to be
completely neutral neutralize our
shipping footprint our carbon footprint
nobody cared about that four years ago
even our most like hard core members was
like do you free shipping we actually
get we get as many enquiries today about
carbon neutral shipping as we do about
free shipping so people really are
starting to care about that you know
reusable vessels we were 98% virgin free
virgin plastic free and all of our
packaging you know we went fully
recyclable in our packaging zero waste
fulfillment like these are topics that
were not in the zeitgeist five years ago
for most consumers even a natural
organic consumers today they absolutely
are so I would say if I were to pick the
top three I'd say environmental
responsibility keto and plant-based are
probably the three the three big ones
and then within there there's all sorts
of flavors and so if you let's break
down the what was the largest one of
these at Quito let's break that down a
little bit like is it you know is it
Quito snackbars is it Quito you know
like like you know a Soylent version of
Quito can you break a dead Quito
everything is key to Quito averages Kido
Kido Kido Kido strips right for the
actual testing for for your ketone
levels its exhaust owns which are like
you can actually like ingest ketones to
make it to go ketogenic it is it is a
bunch of different products that are
keto per se but map to the keto keto
diet whether it's nuts and seeds or it's
MCT oil or it's collagen peptides you
know it's it's it's incredible it's like
it's been absolutely amazing it's a
number one acquisition strategy as well
historic again now withstanding this
moment which is very different with
the way to cope at 19 but by his store
and you know very interesting by the way
and a crisis people have stopped
thinking about their diet all right they
just want to get healthy food but in a
normal time people are absolutely
obsessed with keto and it's the number
one acquisition strategy we have that's
interesting I definitely
but let me talk a little bit more about
like you know you said keto is your
number one acquisition strategy you've
grown from you know thirty million
dollars a year one on the backs of
influencers to hundreds of millions of
dollars in revenue today you know you
went from zero dollars in paid marketing
spent with a bunch of the affiliates to
what I imagine is much more robust
marketing budget like I think I've seen
you guys run TV ads out of home ads I'm
sure you're doing Facebook Ads
you know where are you spending money
today when you're when you're trying to
do paid acquisition yeah I mean we're
still overwhelmingly did it we
definitely pulled in some of the more
traditional channels but you know paid
social works for us paid social in
combination with influencer works really
well for us influence what does that
mean that like an influencer sort of
posting something and you promoting that
that Facebook post we've done that we've
had actually done advertiser access with
the with influencers that we have really
great partnerships with and obviously
they control the message of the content
but we pay for the media we've also just
seen that if we run Facebook ads with
our influencers likeness and again in
partnership with them and all the
content they can perform extremely well
we also see that if somebody you know
when we're spending on it's an ecosystem
right so people most people even if
you're doing last click attribution
there's there's multiple touches that
are contributing to that conversion and
so you know we will see that facebook
has something top of funnel builds
awareness and then when it partnered
with you know you do a partnership
promotion you that they've nothing to do
with each other those two sources spend
contribute to both both channels being
more efficient so influencers actually a
real renaissance for us since we split
out that funnel so it's interesting on
Instagram is you'd imagine it's it's
overwhelmingly mobile traffic same thing
actually on Facebook
but Instagram especially and especially
with so many of our influencers being
Instagram influencers we were seeing
that when you try to get somebody to
start a trial well place in that first
order the chance you were gonna get that
conversion in that moment on the phone
when someone's going through their
Instagram feed given that it takes 40 or
50 minutes is just super super well yeah
so you had one an attribution issue
where people were finding us through
Instagram but we're then converting
later and not being attributed but to
you just had a lot of fall-off right in
the funnel so as we switch to a simpler
funnel let people sign up directly for
membership gave them monthly and annual
options all of a sudden our influencer
channel just started performing like
dramatically better like 50% better in
terms of in terms of last click
contributed CPA which has allowed us now
to go a lot more influencers to promote
more heavily with our with our top
influencers and so that's now you know
it was overwhelming their largest
channel for a long time than it wasn't
now it is again which has been super I'm
sorry what was your overwhelming was at
Facebook or Instagram or are you sort of
influence our influence or is knowledge
Facebook's had its moments I wouldn't
say we spend a lot of time talking about
Facebook I'd probably say a lot of dumb
stuff since you're the Facebook master
but we we have struggled honestly with
Facebook and I think only in recent
months started to understand its role in
the funnel and you know if you're lucky
enough to have native on your hands
where you can actually make last quick
work with Facebook yeah and then back
out on that like you know an actual
attributed CPA basis you're very lucky
we can't but yet what we found is it
does serve a really important role in
the funnel and when you start to when
you you know when you get away from just
like the myopic last-click way of
looking at things and you start to think
about what is the true CPA and I'm not
even talking about multi-touch
attribution I'm just talking about
intuitively putting your team in half
yeah I'm thinking more broadly about
what it's doing in your in your
marketing ecosystem and we've done some
tests to lists to just actually try to
quantify that it's really significant so
we've actually interestingly been
leaning into Facebook a lot more
over the last six to nine months and a
lot of that also has to do with the with
simpler and so if influence was your
number one channel what is your number
two channel what is your number three
channel number one channel might spend
as influencers number two would be I
would be Facebook and what is the matter
you paid search and we've had three paid
search and paid shopping with actually
but our biggest channels and that is
that is to me an artifact of us like
over focusing on the bottom of the
funnel right because last click will
tell you those channels comfort really
really well yeah they're also stealing a
lot of conversion definitely Google used
to tell me there'd be like where you're
like cheapest CPA and I'm like take out
all branded search terms and branded ads
from this and then what is the CPA and
they're like why would you ever do that
and I'm like somebody just found our
product on Facebook Google this product
click the ad and you're trying to claim
all the credit for this yeah I mean I
guess breakthrough we ever I don't know
if this is I know this podcast isn't
just about marketing but the biggest
breakthrough we ever had on paid search
was to split our branded and non-branded
paid search like they're two totally
different atoms nothing right like you
don't even I will literally like scream
if I'm in a meeting
where people talk about our CPA I'm paid
search as a whole as like and then it's
in degree more yeah do you have a $60
CPA but your CPA on branded is $10 in
your CPA and nom read it is 200 your
peanut butter so for $200 you get yeah
yeah I'm like branded search is a tax
that Google Google forces you to pay so
that you don't lose the search you know
the search box or something else and you
know Google whenever I'd explain that to
my Google rep Google would be like oh I
guess I get what you mean and I'm like
you must have heard this from everybody
else like nobody thinks of Google's
branded search as like a real
acquisition it's [__] acquisition
it's somebody finding your product
somewhere else and sort of pang Google
for paint you have to you having to pay
Google for it we only have a few minutes
left I want to ask a few fun questions
what is your favorite product on threat
market I mean that's like asking who's
your favorite child right
I love them all they all end right now
you have one kid so you have an answer
to that it's a yeah it's super easy and
then I guess I would probably go with
the with the first product right which I
was our extra virgin organic Fairtrade
coconut oil I mean that's the one that
started it all uh it was both it's a
pretty dense addition it was our
acquisition hook and it's an amazing
product now we're doing a fully
regenerative which is also super
exciting can you talk about the best
selling product on thrive like I don't
know if you say no it's popular I
already mentioned its collagen peptides
so so II two years ago or five years ago
collagen was basically a beauty product
now it's become a health supplement so
just you're like amazingly the industry
that has emerged that is now taking
bovine collagen and converting it into
high-quality source of protein what is
like um you know I we you and I've hung
out a few times you're generally
incredibly healthy person what's an
indulgence product that you still buy
off of thrive market like do you get
haagen-dazs on private market or from
like from somewhere else besides dry
market actually both another one no both
oh interesting um I mean on private
market it's definitely chocolate so you
know I hope her dark like dark dark dark
dark dark dark but there's you now have
this and this is also a huge trend we
didn't talk about that kind of ties into
Kyoto but you know the the sort of sugar
free sweets are blowing up for us and
whether it's brands like smart sweets or
lillies chocolate
you know monk breed sweetened chocolate
has been incredibly incredibly popular
LeConte oh I love lilies I can eat a
whole one of those bars so that would be
my indulgence on thrive got your off
thrive I don't buy a lot of junk food
but I'll tell you the like one candy I
cannot resist is skittles skittles yeah
like I'll buy one of those like giant
bags at the movie theater and finish it
halfway through the movie wow that's
crazy
okay well thrive market ever sell its
branded products in brick-and-mortar
stores yes one hundred one hundred
percent whether that's in someone else's
brick-and-mortar stores or ours
is the decision we'll have to make okay
gotcha um this is not a fun question his
Co vat19 been good for you or bad for
you I mean it's it's a it's a national
and obviously international crisis it
has been a huge opportunity and we feel
like a responsibility for us to step in
and obviously provide at a level that
we've never had to so you know we it's
gone from like finding healthy groceries
into something that a lot of American
families were thinking about to getting
access to any groceries or something
every American family is thankful about
so you know I would never say it's been
good for us
it is definitely created volume for our
business it's created a insane number of
challenges on the back end but it's you
know it is the ultimate moment for a
mission like this is our opportunity to
go you know truly make it accessible the
time when people don't have a lot of
options yeah and I don't mean I
certainly don't mean like covin 19 being
like evidence throwing parties cuz
there's two - 19 I really mean like
right has a business perspective ya know
we are at the we're in the opposite yeah
okay finally but this is gonna be my
last question because we're almost out
of time you know you guys have raised
hundreds of millions of dollars in
revenue hundreds of millions of dollars
in PC funding you guys there there's
four co-founders a team of what must be
a couple hundred people I think the last
time I visited the office hundreds of
million dollars in revenue who what is
the exit strategy with this business
will you be working here ten years you
know Jeff Bezos is never gonna quit
Amazon Mark Zuckerberg is never gonna
leave Facebook will you ever leave
thrive market is that happen in the next
24 months five years five to ten years
like where where when does this happen
yeah I guess the way I would answer that
question is every time that I have tried
to predict the future even one year out
in the past I've ended up being so
wildly wrong and I don't do it anymore
you know we we were building this
business for the long term whether I'm
the right person to be the CEO ten years
from now I don't know what I like to be
the leader of where I think this
business is going absolutely do I think
we have the opportunity to build a
business that is doing billions if that
tens of billions of dollars in sales I
absolutely do do I think that this
mission has to be achieved I think that
it's it's ludicrous that it's easier and
cheaper to buy highly processed
denatured foods that healthy and organic
ones and I think it's it's bad for
people's health and it's destroying the
destroying the planet so whether it's
thrive market or something else like
this has to happen in the world and and
so I believe that we are well more well
better position than anyone else to do
it and I would be very very happy if we
were sitting here ten years from now and
I was still plugging away on thrive
market and we were having the impact
that I believed we could and are your
investors clamoring like you know at
native we didn't really have like we
didn't have a lot of investors and so we
didn't have anyone clamoring for returns
like you were an investor you weren't
cool I didn't want you to sell it I
would have loved you too I wanted to
keep going yeah fair enough
in fact you weren't the only one when I
called a couple people and told them we
were selling the business they're like
[__] you and I was like holy [__] we're
returning you know significant returns
on a capital investment but yeah by the
way they did but I should have said this
the very beginning part of the reason
I'm honored to be on this cause I think
native is the best investment in the
shortest time on that I've ever had and
it has made me look smarter to so many
people the night and I really am as an
investor so thank you for that know our
investors are patient like that was one
of the really advantageous things of
bringing in people that aligned with the
values and the mission is they want to
get to the same place we want to get to
and it doesn't mean that the right
strategic thing for the business may not
be to find a partner at some point it
doesn't mean that we may not choose to
go public and and and create liquidity
for our investors but you know when we
go public that's not the end of the
business that's the beginning of the
business certainly right if we choose a
partner it's not because we're trying to
wash our hands and walk away it's
because we think that's gonna accelerate
our path to scale so you know I think
that for us the greatest asset in our
business is that long term vision and
the willingness to plan for that and act
act in that direction versus optimizing
for a short-term outcome and I think if
we continue to do that wherever wherever
the outcome lands like it's gonna be you
know we're gonna have a
tremendous impact okay finally you know
if you're you guys were based in LA I
tweeted yesterday that I was gonna
interview for this podcast and a bunch
of people said hey we want to sell our
small like we want to sell our small
businesses product to thrive market
what's the best way to get in touch with
your buyers is it LinkedIn is it a bad
idea because you guys have a limited SKU
set or are you still looking for new
products we're always looking for new
products right like we want to find that
light that innovative product that's on
the bleeding at the edge of the trend
curve that's doing something really
unique that has really strong values
that has a great founder that is what we
live for
and so yes like email our buyers ping
them on LinkedIn you can go online and
actually submit like literally like
submit a form that will go into our
buyers we read every single one of those
a lot of our best products have come in
straight through the front door so no
we're always looking we are incredibly
discerning we reject you know 30 to 50
brands for every one that we bring in
but we are always looking yeah and just
as a note you guys rejected native which
I loved is a story by the way I know I I
don't I don't know card oh you're a
controller no no no I leave me I push no
I love the independence of your buyers
to be like this isn't the right product
for our consumers even though you as an
investor in the CEO of the company we're
pushing in one direction your buyers
were saying no I love the ability that
you have look of buyers to be able to
sort of stand up to you sort of said
this isn't the right product for us
that's right okay fantastic Nick this
was great I I want to sign off by
thanking you for three things one is
doing this podcast two is certainly
investing in native and sort of being
this fantastic resource that I had for
years I remember I'd call you up we chat
on the weekends because both of us
worked on the weekends and you were like
this calming rational force you were the
only person telling me not to expand
into 15 other categories and I really
appreciated that and and finally like
when we sold the business and I sort of
emailed all of our investors asking them
to sign the docs you congratulated me
and you said I bet you built this
business the way you wanted to and I
really appreciated that I was trying to
build native the way that I thought was
right for me as a CEO
as an operator and not for anyone else
and I think that made that cause you
know there were a lot of mistakes that
we made as a result of that and you know
possibly selling was one of them
certainly the business is a lot bigger
today than it was two years ago but that
note meant a lot to me and like I still
read it from time to time and I really
appreciate you saying that to me so so
thanks for all three of those things
really appreciate your presence in my
life that that means so much and I
appreciate you saying that and and that
note reflected one of the things that I
learned from you was just was that
maniacal focus and that willingness to
do it exactly the way you wanted to so
it's it's been a two-way street and much
more to come Nick thanks so much for
your time really appreciate this
[Music]